mitsuru sasaki is a talented japanese
chef known for having the taste buds of
a mythological giraffe he never forgets
the taste of the food he eats and is
always spot on when copying dishes even
without a recipe one afternoon a
bed-ridden man and his wife call him to
make a last meal for the dying man
sasaki comes to the hospital room with a
table fitted with all the ingredients
and utensils the dish he is making is a
simple fried rice and omelet but it has
to be exactly like the one the man and
his wife used to have when they were
young they watch him closely as he
showcases his skills with knives halfway
through the cooking the familiar aroma
of omelette spreads around the room
shocking the couple it is spot on with
how their house smelled like every
morning when they were young and
struggling at last they get to taste the
food and tear up because of the memories
it brings after devouring it all the man
declares it his last meal and asks his
wife to reward the chef for his work
sasaki is thanked but he doesn't show
any emotion while being praised all he
cares about is the 1 million yen he is
getting to cook the dish somewhere else
sasuke's best friend ken is at a funeral
sassaki and ken were brought up in a
children's home by the director recently
he passed away but sasuke refuses to go
to his funeral a flashback reveals that
the director never supported their
decision to learn culinary art hence ken
and sassaki ran away from the children's
home when they were teens ken kept in
touch with the director but saseki never
did which is why he doesn't feel like he
deserves to be at the funeral ken calls
him repeatedly because it was the
director's last wish to meet his
son-like boy but sassaki hangs up
without listening we find out that
sasuke's restaurant failed a while ago
which put him in a lot of debt currently
he makes money by cooking rich people
their final meals a flashback shows that
the restaurant was doing pretty well and
was renowned for its authentic taste
however because of sassaki's
perfectionist nature he threw away a lot
of dishes made for the customers if they
weren't perfect this caused his
employees to hate the work environment
and ultimately no one wanted to work
with him that night saseki gets a call
from an agent asking him to come to
china to cook the last dish for someone
important they offer him three million
yen for a single dish he deals sassaki
cannot refuse the next day he lands in
beijing and meets the said important
person he is an old man named seimei yo
a chef respected by every chinese
culinary artist he cooked for generals
and emperors during the time of world
war ii and is regarded as a legend of
east asian and european cuisine sasuke
is confused as to why someone like yo
wants him to cook his last dish why
doesn't he cook his own damn final meal
the man introduces himself before
revealing that a teacher now taro taught
him to cook everything he knows now taro
paved the way for his career and made
him into who he is today when they were
in manchuria during world war ii they
created 112 dishes each made with
different flavors and different cooking
techniques they were the rarest world
delicacies but the recipes have been
lost no one knows now taro's whereabouts
but yo believes that he still has the
recipe book sasaki's job is to find now
taro's book and cook the dishes he
created since the work is tedious he
will be compensated with 50 million yen
the money will pay off all of sasaki's
debt but he is still unsure about the
task he goes to ken's local restaurant
with the 3 million yen he got as in
advance and asks him for advice being a
good friend ken gives him a green light
to accept the task because even if he
fails he has nothing to lose the next
day sassaki goes to a government office
and looks at now taro's ancestry he
discovers that the man retired in 1964
but no one knows what happened to him
after that while looking through the
pages someone named tatsumi catches his
eye he seems to have been a close friend
of naotaru who might know his
whereabouts in the following scene
sasaki goes to tatsumi's house and finds
out he has been dead for over a decade
however his wife gives him the address
of another man who might be able to help
him the man's name is kamata and he was
now taro's helper when he was in
manchuria kamato lives on a secluded
mountain running a small restaurant he
discloses that he doesn't have the
recipe book but he can tell sasuke how
the recipes were created from there the
story goes into a flashback in 1933
nataro his wife chitsu and a young
kamata came to manchuria for the first
time they were called by the japanese
army general who wanted naotaro to
create the best delicacies for the
emperor about to visit in a few months
now taro was given his private kitchen
with all the ingredients and equipment
he needed they were also introduced to a
chinese helper named yo none other than
the old man who is now a retired
world-famous chef sassaki is shocked
upon hearing the name of the person who
hired him yo was arrogant on his first
day he comments that the japanese cannot
make dishes better than manchurians but
now taro doesn't take it to heart he
instead asks the helper to make
something for the family because they
are tired
shut up and cook you peasant yo makes a
famous watermelon dish and puts
something special in it which he claims
is a secret ingredient after devouring
the food now taro gets up and skillfully
creates an exact replica of it yo tastes
the food and is astonished because the
chef has nailed the taste exactly even
without the secret ingredient natara
reveals that he never forgets the taste
of the food he eats a unique talent he
has learned over the years yo is much
more welcoming after the incident they
start working together beginning the
next day and the first dish yo makes is
a manchurian spring roll now taro puts a
twist on the dish creating a version
that suits both asian and european taste
buds this spring roll has fish and meat
inside and is delicious back in the
present kamata makes the same dish for
sasuke and asks him to taste it even the
critical chef is blown away by the taste
but he comments that the amount of salt
could be reduced kamata freezes in shock
as the comment sounds a little too
familiar to him now taro frequently used
to comment that he puts too much salt in
everything back when they worked
together moreover he was very critical
of the food he created and threw away
anything that wasn't a hundred percent
perfect much like how sassaki is after
naotaro's first week in manchuria the
army general is presented with the first
dish he came up with the man devours it
all and allows him to create more of
such dishes as work continues chitsu
takes on the responsibility of being the
group's photographer she also helps her
husband write the recipes down at the
end of every day but refrains from
helping in the kitchen because she is
pregnant we are also introduced to the
regular military chefs whose job is to
cook for the people on the base they do
not go inside this special kitchen
knowing that it is for experimental and
special purposes the chief cook and his
son are always eager to socialize and
grow close to chitsu with time one day
naotaro introduces the concept of 112
dishes assigned to four respective
seasons they will continue creating new
dishes and adding them to the wall
innovating and removing some in the
process in the following montage we see
them experimenting with many foods from
around the world the wall eventually
fills up with recipes and they finally
make 112 new dishes the team wants to
celebrate but now taro surprises them by
tearing off some of the dishes according
to him their real challenge has just
started because now they have to pick
the good ones out and throw away the
average ones for the next few months now
taro immerses himself in work but fails
to come up with new ideas chitsu sees
him struggling and advises him to start
trusting his colleagues up until now now
taro only trusted his craft and didn't
believe yo and kamada could come up with
great ideas chitsu knows that he can
only win if he keeps this arrogance
aside a few days after that chitu gives
birth and passes away not even an hour
later the head cook finds naotaro in the
kitchen cooking something and calls him
out for being a heartless man now taro
reveals that he is making chitsu's
favorite dish and they enjoy a feast in
her memory now the responsibility of his
newborn daughter is entirely in his
hands back in the present kamata stops
talking and gives sasaki the address of
a russian man named joseph saseki has to
go to him to hear the rest of the story
upon reaching joseph's restaurant he
finds out the man is dead but his son
robert is ready to tell him anything he
wants to know robert used to be best
friends with naotaro's daughter misa
when she was a child at one point in
history now taro was called to cook for
a jewish exchange party where he met
joseph it is also when robert and misa
met for the first time now taro and
joseph have their differences at first
but now taro manages to impress him with
his non-traditional cabbage roll dish it
has elements of russia japan and china
making it a perfect dish for meeting
with people of all these nations the
meeting was highly successful and all
credit went to nataro this marked the
beginning of naotaru and joseph's
friendship at present sasaki has offered
the cabbage dish that joseph's
restaurant still serves today he is yet
again blown away by another of notaro's
dishes after devouring it sasaki
inquires where the recipe book with 112
dishes is robert reveals that one
afternoon naotaro came to joseph in a
hurry and trusted him with the recipe
book and a letter at that time manchuria
was swarming with spies from different
communist parties now taro was told yo
was a chinese spy who had not only been
keeping an eye on them but was selling
the recipes to outsiders the betrayal
prompted now taro to kick yo out of the
base asking him to never return sasuke
is in shock that the person he met at
the beginning of all this was the
villain but then robert hits him with
another surprise disclosing that now
taro asked joseph to give the recipe
book to yo this means the old man had
the recipe this whole time but he still
made sasaki run around for it after
finally figuring everything out he goes
to yo and inquires what the last piece
of the puzzle is yo still says that he
doesn't have the recipes and asks him to
read the last letter left by nataro in
it now taro discloses that he was asked
to poison the japanese emperor when he
came to feast in their establishment the
army general is being given a lot of
money to do so and is offering the same
to naotaro if the plan goes right they
will blame you for poisoning the emperor
because he is chinese not just that but
kamada turns out to be a japanese spy
sent to keep an eye on naotaro and the
group now taro doesn't have the option
to refuse the offer so instead he kicks
yo out of the establishment to save his
own life however the general doesn't
give up still asking now taro to cook
for the emperor and poison the food
hence the night before the food trial
now taro copies a second recipe book and
hands it over to joseph on the day of
the trial he burns the original copy of
the book angering the general because
his plan is now ruined as a result now
taro is imprisoned to ask for
forgiveness kamada tries to break his
master free at last but before he
succeeds the general shoots naotaro dead
his daughter misa remains with the head
cook who takes care of her like his own
daughter soon the sino-japanese war
starts and he brings his son and misa to
japan to save their lives yo says that
he made connections with japanese high
profiles and climbed the ladder of
success
meanwhile kamada went to war several
years later they reunite and look for
misa because she is the true heir of the
recipe book they find her still with the
head cook and his son who she calls her
elder brother she also has a little son
but her husband turns out to be dead on
finding out about her father misa breaks
into tears and promises to open a
restaurant using his recipes to honor
him everything goes well until the day
of the restaurant's opening it lights on
fire and misa dies trying to save the
recipe book her poor kid screams for his
mother but she never returns the book
however was miraculously saved a few
days after her death her elder brother
took the responsibility to take care of
her son and established a children's
home for less fortunate children this is
when sassaki realizes that the kid is
himself now that's food for thought he
is now taro's grandson and mises son who
lost his family and was raised by his
uncle in a children's home yo sent him
out on this mission so he would find out
about the history of culinary art in his
family through research in the end the
director wanted to meet him before dying
because he had the recipe book and he
wanted to hand it over to its rightful
owner but instead of being handed the
thing up front sasaki got to travel the
world and get paid 50 million bucks so
i'd say he made the right choice at last
we see sasuke return to the children's
home and pay respect to his uncle's
shrine he finally receives the recipe
book and sees the pictures of his family
on it his uncle didn't want him to
become a chef because he had seen his
family suffer due to their obsession
with food in the final scene sasaki
recreates his grandfather's dishes for
the children of the establishment
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching